[Music]
right through the city like British I'm
on a mission to get it all right through
the city like British if you ain't thick
please don't get involved
now Brandon
what's popping fam Monday morning
October 24th your boy is here what's
Poppin how's everybody doing was your
weekend good hey pants getting ready to
gramping up for Halloween how's those
costumes looking the moms out there did
you make the costume eyes prefer for the
parents to make the costume so it's a
little more unique my mom used to make
mine that's where you saw the French
robot the infamous French robot which I
will post every Halloween to the day I
die so you can bet your sweet sweet
chops I'm gonna post that uh coming up
here I was this French robot and I
handed out uh croissants to all the kids
and my mom was not happy there we are
look at that dude what a lit outfit
what's that second one go to the second
one in there
okay I don't know what that is uh
that I think that's
is that my brother because that's not me
on the right it looks it looks like my
brother but I don't know who that is on
the right
you know I think that someone might have
recreated the French robot outfit there
oh that didn't show up
interesting I don't know
yeah I don't know either if I had to
guess so that looks like Jay and this
could be you that's not me I know but no
I know for a fact yes no no that is not
me or maybe just Jay and his friend uh I
don't he wouldn't make that face I don't
know if that is my bro or maybe just two
people that have similar ish
costumes to your French robot and they
just put my brother the kids I'm a robot
on the left that's just like a weird but
this scarecrow I think that kid redid
the the French robot and then if you see
then you go on the other one it's me as
a tiger and Jay is a ninja that one's
pretty lit too look at that dude at the
sweet Adidas on my brother's probably
willing to kill me if that was a real
knife it's not my brother's so serious
God I look like bossy though uh that's
interesting man
yeah so parents shout out to all the
parents out there uh oh wow yeah that's
that's uh that's me with my He-Man toy
there that's my son that's tiger that's
tiger when he's looking yeah he's
getting big look he's big mitts there
he's just Buzz Lightyear too lit lit
um yeah man coming off a great weekend
shout out to Salt Lake City Wise Guys
with my favorite Club shout out to Keith
my favorite clubs ever uh I've hit
London I don't know six times one of my
very very favorite Club it's always a
good time and uh it was a big deal out
there because For the First Time Ever we
decided to bring fight campaign on the
on on the road
um and uh you know
it's tough to pull off on the road my
boy Casey's here he's the uh producer of
it and he was exhausted and he was so
nervous about it
um but uh we pulled it off man uh I sent
out the the thick boy bat signal my boy
uh Jesse on fire if you don't uh know
who Jesse on Fires you should he's one
of the main voices in the space as far
as MMA goes here's a big uh YouTube
channel called Jesse on fire Jesse on
fire he's just an overall great dude
he's based out of Texas and decided to
fly out just for His companion I sent
out the thick boy bat signal now my boy
Frank Mayer on the right Frankie on the
right there one of the legends of the
sport they both flew in Frank was
actually going to be there because
um him and his partner Harrison uh
partner not like uh you know partner LA
partner like uh his business partner
Harrison
um came out there to come to the comedy
show so I was like hey I'll let you come
a little early so we knock out this
companion because I can't remember last
time I was this excited for a uh for a
UFC fight man I I went to bed thinking
about it it's you know it's rare when
you're this crunk for an entire card and
man there was just some bangers the top
four card uh fights were bangers on the
card you had Leo Mohammed and Sean Brady
on there and the prelims which was
ridiculous so
um we tried to get it done we pulled it
off we pulled off shot to Casey and Chin
for flying out there shout out to Keith
that Wise Guys for last the space to
pull off and having a good internet
connection this thing that makes
combat's fight campaign or Salt Lake
City fight campaign the challenge is
it's live and when you do live you need
good uh internet connection otherwise if
that live feed goes down uh the show's
ruined so uh it was a fun one man it was
a lot of fun if you haven't seen it yet
um we did do it live but as soon as it
goes live and once that live stream ends
it gets uploaded to the page as a
regular episode so if you haven't seen
it yet it's available right now it's a
good one and this card was perfect to do
a fight campaign for B because uh it was
one hell of a card man I thought it
lived up to the hype and then some I
thought the the fights that I thought
were gonna be uh
competitive weren't and then the fights
that I thought were gonna be kind of you
know the big heavy favorite you know
those weren't so that's what makes MMA
great
um you know my picks uh let's see I took
Sean Brady over muhammadil you know I
love you but you know Big Sean Brady
fence I took chambray I was wrong on
that I took Darius I was right on that I
took sugashan I was right on that I took
TJ I was wrong on that and then I took
Charles I was wrong on that so that's
what is that I think I was two four
five
two out of five
um you know and out of those uh the two
that I won were the were the dogs they
were the dogs and yeah so I think
chambray was a slight favorite maybe
going into it right chin so Brady was a
favorite
um Darius was a slight Underdog sugar
Sean was an underdog TJ was an underdog
Charles Oliver was not a dog so I took
all underdogs and one favorite I
definitely lost on the favorite against
Sean Brady but the card overall I
thought was fantastic man it was a great
card a lot to get into so let's just
jump right into this UFC 280 uh
basically recap show let's jump right
into the pool I'm just gonna Cannonball
riding kids I was kicking off with uh
Muhammad Vashon Brady wow what a
freaking fight what a performance for
Muhammad
um you know Muhammad this guy who flies
under the radar and that welterweight
division a little bit but if you look
how active he's been and how many top 10
guys he's beat especially in the in
recent times it's pretty damn impressive
man so he's won goof My God
it's it it's very similar to uh to
Darius like these guys man so out of his
last one two three four five six seven
eight nine ten eleven twelve thirteen
fourteen fights he's lost one
and out of his last 15 fights right so
he's he's 13 and two of his last 15. one
of those fights he and beat the guy
recently Vicente lucay so his last 15
fights and that was in 2016. he left
Vicente Luke he got knocked out in a
minute which can happen you know Cynthia
Luke is a Savage he ended up fully
redeeming himself so that's nullified uh
besides that he's only lost a decision
to kneel
and he's beat you ready he's beat uh you
know he had the no contest against Leona
that was a shame that was that had been
a big one for him but then Damian Maya
Wonderboy Thompson Vicente Luke remember
Vicente Luce before he fought blue
Mohammed came off food truck thought he
was using to get a title shot or Nate
Diaz they gave him Muhammad Muhammad
beat him pretty soundly for uh three
rounds right those three rounds or us
five rounds sorry for the five round
fight and then they give him the
freaking Savage the Philadelphia Savage
still Savage the even the Philadelphia
Savage undefeated young Philadelphia
lion Sean Brady which I thought was an
awful matchup for him and he kind of
beat the breaks off of him TKO punches
that just stopped it earlier too he he
came out and he he really he got
performance tonight too which he
definitely deserved
um so you know hats off to Blue Mohammed
for him at the wealth away division that
you know they got to do something with
him when you've won 13 out of 15 and one
of those fights you've redeemed yourself
and convincedly beat the guy for five
rounds you got to give him a top three
matchup you have to I would love to see
him against Colby Covington I know they
want to do the hamzat thing the Leo
Muhammad deserves it and believe falls
into the the same category and we'll
move on the next fight where uh Darius
at lightweight at 55 they give him gam
rot
you know and I was upset because I'm a
Darius fan I love Darius I think he's
such a talent but you know them give him
gamma that's not doing any favors and he
was also a slight Underdog in that fight
for a good reason and he outshined uh uh
camera not you know two of The Judds
gave it 30 27 which I thought they had
that spot on
um
so
you know Darius and bilio Muhammad are
in this weird thing where they both
definitely deserve title shots are they
gonna get it probably not which is such
a shame because they definitely deserve
it and the others any other sport it's
very black and white who's going to win
you know uh play for the championship
it's very black and white UFC is a
little different right because there's
some other things other narratives that
go into a guy getting a title shot both
of them clue if this is
six seven years ago they both of them
have already fought for a title but the
landscape's different now Instagram
followers Twitter twitch and all that
[ __ ] and you know uh it's selling the
fight everything goes into that which is
a little Shame Shame uh because the UFC
model isn't predicated off that off
pay-per-view buys right because now that
their their boss is Mickey Mouse and
they get paid regardless of how many
pay-per-views they sell obviously they
always want to do well but you're
getting paid regardless so I would
expect guys like Darius and guys like
Leo Muhammad to get title shots but
that's not the case uh I thought Darius
had just amazing performance we knew
gamrat was it was coming heavy on the
wrestling but Darius is grappling uh was
the hit Factor there and he was beating
him in scrambles and just a ridiculous
performance he gets on the mic and I
told you guys guys going into this hey
you shouldn't be in fighting camera it's
a nightmare of magic Form B part of the
reason why he's not getting a title shot
is because Darius
it's he doesn't know any other way to do
it because he's true to himself and he's
obviously very has faith and he's very
religious and there's nothing wrong with
that and I'm actually jealous of it I
wish I had more of it and that's
actually the Green Room diary bit and I
sell myself I'm becoming Mormon but it
they didn't accept me which is a shame
because I feel like it could bring some
value to them but um they wouldn't let
me in the church so the point is Deus is
organic to himself and he gets on the
mic and goes I don't care about Tire
shot I fight 10 guys you know I give all
praise to my Lord and Savior Jesus
Christ and
he's just such a goody two-shoes quote
unquote that it's hard for the UFC to
Market that that makes sense
unfortunately
but if you look at their landscape and
the way they do business
it shouldn't matter Terry should be
fighting for a title but he's definitely
not and then also they also weigh heavy
on what you do when you give those WWE
type promos when you get on the mic to
help them navigate your next fight so
when he gets on there and goes I don't
care I'll fight 10 guys until I get a
title shot even if you look at his
record goes records and it's ridiculous
you're probably gonna fight 10 guys you
know the UC goes yeah sure you don't
care we don't care man we have other
guys in line 55 is getting pretty you
know dicey so he's won one two three
four five six seven eight fights in a
row one of those over Tony Ferguson and
the over is over gamron you know so
there's definitely a case there to be
had that he should be fighting for a
title what they shouldn't do in one of
those fights was a fight of the night
he's had three performance of the night
so his fighting style doesn't match his
uh
cutting promos style his fighting style
very entertaining very uh loose very
um
dangerous he gets clipped and it's game
on for for Darius and he's everything
you want in a fighter except for what
the UFC uh kind of awards which is
giving these WWE type promos you know
you're not gonna see any guy in the WWE
given a Jesus Christ promo so I don't
know they don't know what to do and be
so goddamn good nothing he's 33 so I
don't know how long he's gonna keep this
up so he could get a 21st in situation
where they tried to give him title shots
before everything he was getting hurt I
don't think deers should get hurt even
though he got hurt before but I think
it's just be a matter by the time he
gets there Father Time surprising to
touch him on the shoulder that's gonna
be too late which is
such a shame and isn't right you know it
just isn't
so that leaves me to the next fight
where if you watch the companion or you
watched uh shop show last week I said if
Sean O'Malley wins he's gonna be the
conversation no matter what happens with
the other two fights the main event
co-main event I ca I I stick by that
because Sean O'Malley's definitely the
topic of conversation Monday morning on
October 24th when the fight was on
Saturday
is the topic of conversation for a
variety of reasons a the way he won a
the controversial way he won with the
judge's decisions what decision
um and then also C to thirdly to that
point is he's also the biggest star on
the card and he did win so it checks all
boxes controversy which the UFC loves in
the market check the star the the young
line the colorful line with pink hair
that talks all the stuff and is very
um you know dominant on social media and
twitch check you know and then also the
biggest check to me the biggest takeaway
from all this besides all the garbage
going online right now and all the hate
that Sugar Sean's getting is
he's the real deal
he's the real deal and he's an elite
fighter
so you know I I text Sean O'Malley this
this morning you know guys that get a
lot of hate I have my black belt and
hate I have my master master degree
dealing with haters
and I I told Sean O'Malley this this is
how I approach it if what they're hating
on right now infuriates them which sugar
Shawn gives you a lot of reasons to Hate
About You Know troll guys you know Peter
John won't touch me obviously that's
trolling he knows he's gonna get touched
in a three-round fight with Peter John
the number one bantamweight on the world
of course of course you can't touch he's
doing that to get a rise at you guys
he's trolling you right that's what he
does so he's giving you a lot of reasons
to be mad and be madam
but if you thought you didn't like sugar
sham before
well now the narrative on him was
oh he's just getting these
you know Snowball Fight and he's not
real the UFC just wants to put him up
there he doesn't really have the skill
set he's not Elite well if you were mad
on before I'm gonna give you a lot more
reason to be mad at me now so for sugar
Shawn's sake if you hate him before and
your narrative was he's not a real
fighter he hasn't beat anybody he can't
be anybody in the top five he's never
gonna fight for a title he's not that
good of a striker he's not Elite blah
blah blah
well that's all gone
that's all gone there's no way even if
you can't stand sugar Sean there's no
way you can watch that fight and go he
doesn't deserve to be in there with the
top three guys in the world
because not only did he show out and put
on a great fight even if he lost that
decision you can't tell me he's not a
top five Talent even if the judges
sided with the majority of what the fan
base and the the MMA quote-unquote
experts think which there's really not a
lot of experts in this space experts are
such a loose term when it comes to
sports so new but people that cover it
most the people that cover it when it's
MMA fighting MMA junkie sheer dog you
name it all those things ESPN guys all
those major you know media Outlets all
scored it for Peter Young
let's say that it did go perion's way
even if it did you still can't sit and
tell me that sugashan is an elite
he proved all you guys wrong all the
haters wrong that he is an elite
high-level UFC fighter matter of fact
now he's the elite he's top three easily
as far as striking goes there's a reason
Peter Young was shooting so much
and it ain't because he wanted to
because he's getting pieced up on the
feet
by a guy who's ranked number 11 you're
ranked number one
Peter Young's known for a striking right
he's not his go-to isn't wrestling his
go-to usually is on the feet his
footwork wearing the guy out throwing
combinations knocking guys out didn't
happen when sugar Shawn did it
should Sean's Elite
so if you guys want some to hate on man
you can take a big chunk out of it now
he's just getting started
so if you woke up smart on the wrong
side of the bed and you're upset that
this guy with pink hair the rainbow hair
and the tattoos and he's hanging out
Takashi six nine if you hate him before
he's just getting started you have a lot
of animosity towards that man now
because if he thought he was big before
he just beat the number one bantamweight
in the world
no matter how you feel about it he beat
him
but let's talk about numbers let's just
talk about the fight
in our sport there's always these terms
that get popular and become this
regurgitating theme because people don't
think for themselves so it's oh he's
chinny right that for a long time he's
chinny he's Jenny Cheney was a thing
Chin Chin Chin was the thing I'm not
saying my producer I'm talking about if
a guy lost whether he had you know 10
Knockouts and was on ten fight win
streak he gets clipped oh he's Cheney
it's this whole chin thing that kind of
went away people got more educated it's
very rare they use it maybe it's a
veteran and you know and he is getting
knocked out like a an example of a
person where we say their Chin's gone
would be Bigfoot Silva right that guy I
will accept if you say he's chinny that
works in that case for the rest guys
doesn't really work and the audience
moved on from and got more educated so
we stopped using that well now the new
term is he got robbed It's a Robbery
whether it's a decision whatever Split
Decision majority decision oh he got
robbed I don't don't think you guys know
what the term robbery means if you're
going around throwing that term out
there especially in the case of sugar
Sean O'Malley and Peter Yount nobody got
robbed nothing is a robbery here it was
a split decision a robbery would be a
guy who clearly wins three or five
rounds clearly dominates
and then the judges give it the complete
other way the complete other way 30-27
50 you know whatever 50 45 that's a
robbery it's like Jesus Christ robbery
for example for you guys that like to
use the term would be in the sport of
boxing would be uh Canelo versus Triple
G the first one that's robbery Triple G
definitely won that but they had the
fixes in for Canelo all good he did it
then he ended up you know the second
fight you could also call a robbery the
third one you can't the Canelo Valdez
himself and beat him there even though
he was a lot older either way that first
one would be a robbery a robbery would
be uh Robbie Lawler Condit for the belt
a robbery would be
Machida Shogun Rua the those are
robberies we're clear as day the other
guy dominant a robbery would be for you
guys to use it so you sound educated
when you use the term robbery because
you're using it so much it's lost it's
meaning because now every robbery
robbery oh that's a robbery no it's not
you know what the [ __ ] you're talking
about a robbery would be Johnny
Hendricks GSP that's a robbery
this is an arari Johnny Hendricks no
matter who you talk to you look at that
he won multiple multiple rounds the
majority of the rounds you might give
GSP one there I could see maybe two sure
as hell and no fast at three but these
judges did that would be a robbery this
is not a robbery if you go back and
watch fight which I have four times now
before I came in and made this point
if you go through the rounds one two and
three it would be tough if you take it
without a biased Viewpoint with however
you feel about sugar Sean
if you know a thing or two about the way
they score fights they have a criteria
so it takes out the bias of the fight so
if you went to fight a huge Peter yawn
fan it doesn't matter you have to squirt
on these certain topics you have to
these certain things cage control uh
damage being number one just so let's
make it clear before I make this point
for the judges the number one
determining factor of a round is damage
right remember that before I make this
case the number one criteria in order to
decide who wins a round is damaged not
takedowns not only guy down not octagon
control not aggressiveness
not submissions thrown not kicks landed
not punches thrown the number one thing
you have got to get this in your goddamn
Minds to say robbery the number one
thing is damage
so let's go through the fight
first round is where you're gonna have
most controversy first round even though
Peter John land that big takedown what
did he do with that takedown if you put
your you yourself in the mind of the
judge at UFC 80 in Abu Dhabi in the
arena there and if you're judging this
thing and you're going based off damage
which is number one indicator how we
judge around number one right
you go through that first round and the
reason why the first round is so
important because the second and third
are clear as day who won those rounds
second round is Peter John third round's
sugar Sean easy easy to score those are
easy fight score if you sit back and
analyze those rounds and go based off
the judging criteria which I did not
design I have nothing to do with it but
that's how they judge the fight so if
you're gonna judge the fight based the
way the judges do it which is the only
thing that matters because that who
decides who wins and loses a fight based
off the Damage Done
of those rounds two and three the second
would go to Peter Young although damage
wasn't really inflicted but although
remember so damage number one if there's
no damage being done you got to go down
the line so next would be takedown's
control all right so if no damage done
in the second round takedown's control
second round Peter yon land those
takedowns controlled him for the most
part not a lot of damage was done though
down there so we can't really judge it
based off damage so then we go to
control and takedowns with two most
significant things in that second round
that's Peter on all day say ground Peter
on all day
third round if we go to the number one
judging criteria which is damage
it's not even close in if you want to
and doesn't always tell the The
Narrative of a fight but if you want to
go the copy strike numbers I think Sugar
Land like 40 to 15 or some [ __ ] like
that those aren't exact numbers but it
was in that Realm also the knee which
split Peter Yan open in the third round
was the most significant damage done in
15 minutes of that fight you would give
sugar Shawn that third round clear as
day second round peon Clara's Day first
round that's where you have an argument
now when I was watching it it always
take with a grain of salt if you're
watching uh the Salt Lake City fight
campaign right now after you listen to
this rant if you're watching I go well
you scored it for Peter Young I did but
remember I'm barely paying attention all
I see I I see some shots landed if it's
a big one and everyone goes oh I'll see
that I'm drinking
all right there's some tiger thick
flowing through my veins and third of
all
I just see the takedown the control and
what I I'm looking but then remember I'm
the captain of the ship I have to manage
to make sure the show's entertaining
getting Frank to talking and Jessica
talk I gotta manage these different
personalities while trying to pay
attention to the fight so never take
what I say in the moment of a fight
companion to Heart
so what I do so I have a better
perspective on it is I go back and watch
those fights that are close so I can
really pay attention I I don't listen in
the commentating because that can also
and I would I haven't listened to
commentating on this
I never do especially when I'm before
I'm breaking a fight down I I listen to
it in silence when the kids go to I drop
them off at school I come back I watch
the fight over and over and over thank
God this one's 15 minutes so I was
allowed to watch it a few times
so when you watch it and you're not
you're not swayed by the commentating
because a lot of times when I hear
robbery I go I bet the commentating was
also a little biased towards a certain
fighter because that because again a lot
of people sheep they don't think for
themselves they hear the commentary from
these experts legit experts and they can
skew or sway a fan base so I don't
engage in that I don't listen to any of
that so if you take out your bias you
take out the commentating you watch that
fight you watch the first round punches
landed kicks landed the body shots
if you're old school like me and I
always favor wrestling and grappling
usually in fights
you're gonna give it to Peter Yan but if
you watch it the way they judge and
fight which all that matters you might
say well he didn't stop the takedown he
didn't do this and Peter Young Patrol
for you know this amount of time it does
not matter the way they judge the fight
if significant strikes landed and damage
done and and sugar Shawn did that in
that first round and that's why I would
give the first round to Sugar Shawn
second round Peter Yan third round sugar
Shawn all [ __ ] day if you don't give
the third round of sugar Sean you're
just a hater and you're biased and
that's all good I've been there but it's
not real you know it's real the judges
score card and the judge's scorecard had
it 29 28 for Suga 28.29 for Peter Young
and then the most important one 2928 for
Suga which gave sugar the split decision
over the number one band to wait in the
world
and not only did it validate how [ __ ]
good sugar Shawn is but it gave all you
haters out there more
to chew on so if you hated sugar Shawn
before I'm telling you the kids just
getting started this was his first big
test and he passed it with flying colors
Win Lose or Draw
doesn't matter
sugar Shawn is Elite and you guys hate
that and one of the things that makes
sugar Sean so polarizing and so massive
and popular is because all this talk all
this noise online which none of it
matters all this talk all this stuff
just feeds in you're doing promo for
Suga all the hate anybody gets whether
it's a comic an athlete a fighter a a an
actor you're giving them free promo
because most people think for themselves
so you might cut a YouTube video and go
show you Sean's worst fighter ever
someone's gonna click on that your sugar
Sean's in your mind sugar Sean's out
there you're putting more sugar Shawn
content out there more people than
regurgitate that more people need to get
that but most of them form their own
opinion but you're just giving him free
promo he's getting free promo makes them
bigger makes the machine bigger makes
people want to see them win or lose
makes them want to see him Floyd
Mayweather pay-per-view model we weren't
tuning in for the most part to see Floyd
Mayweather put on an amazing performance
because he fought pretty safe he's so
damn good at he's the best of all time
you're tuned in to see him lose
Floyd Mayweather's bank account does not
care if you're 80 bucks for that pay for
you came because you hate them or
because you love them the bank accounts
don't care sugar Sean's bank account and
his negotiation with the UFC does not
care
whether it's hey these million people
tune in because they want to see sugar
lose cool
these million people tuned in because I
don't see sugar win cool it's all the
same at the end of the day
so your hate for sugar Shawn is helping
him it's building the machine it's
fueling the rocket ship that is tied to
his back now that not only did he prove
every single body wrong
but now there's nothing you can do to
take this away from however you feel
about it on Monday morning sugar Shawn
O'Malley will be ranked probably in the
top two in the world in the bantamweight
division he's not in the top two that's
just [ __ ]
because the guy is clearly Elite and you
guys didn't think he was and you were
wrong
so if you hate them before man he's
gonna be he has a lot more work to do
you hate him even more now because he is
getting his next title shot he is gonna
be the next guy in line to get Tire shot
now for sugar Sean
when he um got on the mic
exhausted three rounds he goes I'll have
to watch fight I'm not even sure I won
that fight I don't know if I deserve a
title shot I'll have to watch it before
I talk about it trust me he's gonna get
back on his social media which is bigger
than the crowd that was tuned into UFC
280 he's gonna get on there I bet you he
will vindicate himself and say I
definitely after watching I definitely
deserve it
because he probably feels a certain type
of way because he's never been that type
of fight before so he didn't do the
usual sugar thing where I didn't get
touched I told you to smoke him because
he was an actual dog fight with the
number one band to wait in the world and
he beat him no he didn't doesn't matter
the judges gave it to him your opinion
on this does not matter my opinion on
this does not matter at the end of the
day
and throughout history when we look back
on this fight card all it says no matter
how you feel about it how you scored at
home how you and your drunk buddy scored
it who have never fought before how all
you guys scored it does not matter
sugar Sean won this fight
those are in the record books
that's all that matters
Talk Amongst yourselves
talks amongst Twitter talks amongst read
it talks amongst share dog talks amongst
the forums talks among YouTube comments
all that noise builds these guys that
you hate even bigger even bigger you're
helping the machine out you're helping
put money and show your Sean's pocket so
continue on shout out to show your Sean
you did it buddy you did it now was it a
Connor Aldo moment no
there's not a Conor Auto moment because
he didn't just starch them and walk off
after 19 seconds
I think this was more important for
sugar Shawn fans because
him going three hard rounds and being
controversial going back and forth we
see Suga he looked tired in that second
round came out the third one the third
significantly won the third that huge
need Landing huge punches wobble and
Peter Young we've never seen Peter John
so much trouble he's damn near about to
get finished getting rocked so many
times
taking sugar down which we expected but
then really not doing anything with it
should just take down defense actually
better than we thought Sugar's defense
down there is actually better than we
thought if you're a fan of sugar we
didn't want the 19 second knockout we
wanted to see if sugar was a stock
if he was a New York a stock right if
he's on the stock market here's the
thing for all those sugar fans out there
he validated everybody's kind of
questions about sugar is he Elite can we
bet on this guy can we Bank on this guy
when the going gets rough and it's not
going his way and gets taken down and if
if he gets rocked on the feet how's he
going to respond we've never seen it so
it's hard to bet on that guy well guess
what we've seen it we've seen it we know
when he gets the title shot against
algerman Sterling when the going gets
rough suga's not going to quit I'll bet
on that guy he's a Fighter's fighter
he's a real fighter I know he has purple
hair pink here where the hell it is
today and rainbow hair but then day you
strip all that down you take the chains
off the tattoos off the twists off the
hanging out the appearances with Takashi
69 and whoever the hell else he's
hanging out with and his him his coaches
are wild and all that stuff you strip
all that away at the end of the day
after UFC 280 there's no doubt about it
sugar Shawn is one of the best batting
weights on the planet hands down and I
can't wait for that for him to get
taught a shot now
after watching that fight is Al Jermaine
a terror fight probably
he's gonna have his hands full there
but at least I know I can bet on him I
know he's not going to give up I know
when it comes to defeat he can
definitely outstrike uh algerbane when
it's on the feet I'd be willing to bet
Sterling's not going to play that game
there's a reason for that because you
can watch that Peter on tape you'll kick
him fight for the first time ever and
suga's career even if you hate the guy
you watch the 15 minutes of him find
Peter Young there's not a single person
in the world that can't say sugar
Shawn's not Elite and he can't fight
that narrows out the window what else
you got
what else you guys are gonna run on
you gotta come up with something what is
it he didn't Pete he didn't beat Peter
Young that's all noise doesn't matter he
did he did
straight up doesn't matter what you
think he beat him what else you got keep
going you gotta haters out there you
gotta come up with something better for
sugar what else you got
come on you gotta come up with something
you should all get together I don't know
where you guys meet whether it's a PF
Chang's Starbucks I don't know where the
hell all these sugars haters meet you
get get whoever the ring leader is and
he got a new narrative because a
narrative oh he's not a real fighter
he's not Elite that doesn't work here he
didn't win that doesn't work here
yes and there could be uh he's being
beat up by Al Jermaine Sterling all
right that's fine that's a fun one do
that
shout out to Sugar Shawn you [ __ ] did
it dude good for you
let's take a little break for me
chatting here off about UFC 280 and why
Suga Sean won this freaking fight uh
tour news listen I'm in Calgary Canada
this Thursday Friday we just had a show
Friday because Thursday's damn near sold
out so we added a show this Friday at
the Rooftop in downtown Calgary that's
Canada baby so I'm coming on up there
one of my favorite markets and then next
week uh it's heavy taxes for two weeks
in a row next week is San Antonio Texas
November 3rd to the 5th I'm in San
Antonio at the LOL
um and then uh the other thing the next
week I'm in Houston so it's next week
San Antonio Texas then the following
week November 10th through the 12th I'm
in Houston Texas at the Houston Improv
with my favorite spots as well I love
Texas so I have a Texas tattoo I've
never not sold out in Texas so here's
the thing though Tech's won the biggest
markets when it comes to Tiger thick so
we're doing a big push there we have
bottles at every show actors told you
about Calgary will have tiger thick San
Antonio tiger thick used to have tiger
thick also in San Antonio and Houston
because I'm in all the spec stores out
there I'll be doing a meet and greet and
giving out tiger thick come try tiger
thick come take pictures come have me
sign whatever you got whatever you got
I'll announce the which specs it is
exactly as we get closer to those dates
but come see your boy at one of the
specs one of the liquor stores out in
Texas and Santo and Houston but if you
haven't had a chance to get the
award-winning thick nectar you can do it
in Calgary San Antonio Houston Milwaukee
Providence and Washington but really in
Santo and Houston big push there we'll
have all the bottles there in Salt Lake
we have uh the tiger thick within the
first two shows so they clearly didn't
ship enough but we sort of have cases of
it so Santo Houston come see me come
meet me try it talk about the whiskey
take pictures do everyone do arm wrestle
take a picture of your babies and try
some of that tiger thick sweet nectar
and if you want delivered to your crib
go to sleep dot com it will show up at
your door you'll see you can click on
tap it says tiger thick fill out from
there shows up at your door easy peasy
Japanese all right this episode of the
shop show UFC 280 recap is brought to
you by Avast a vast one is a global
leader in cyber protection for more than
30 years it's trusted by over 435
million users and prevents over 1.5
billion attacks every month of ASP
empowers you with digital safety and
privacy no matter who you are where you
are or how you get connected enjoy the
opportunities that come with being
connected on your terms a vast new
all-in-one solution of S1 helps you take
control of your safety and privacy
online through a range of features all
right Avast one is their best protection
yet giving you everything you need to
take control of your safety and privacy
online all right and it's accessible
through a single easy to use interface
and we got you man a vast privacy
features keeps your identity actions
hidden maybe you're at a freaking coffee
shop doing business you're using some
Wi-Fi it's for everybody at the airport
you're just you're at the library
wherever you're at who goes libraries
these days you know what I'm saying you
got to protect yourself people are
stealing information Mission we live in
a digital world and we're some digital
girls man and we just gotta figure it
out and protect ourselves that's why I
love a vast one they have anti-virus
award-winning anti-virus that stops
viruses malware from harming your
devices a VPN allowing to connect safely
and securely in public like Starbucks
Coffee Bean wherever you're at using
their Wi-Fi you don't want anybody
knowing where you're at this makes it so
they have no clue where you're at we got
you covered man thanks have asked for
supporting the shop show confidently
take control of your online world with a
vast one it helps you stay safe from
viruses phishing attacks ransomware
hacking attempts and other cyber crimes
all right learn more about avas1 at
avast.com
avast.com go check them out
this episode of the shop show is also
brought to you by happy hippo that's
right happyhippo.com promo codes thick
boy you get 20 for life from the best
Kratom on the planet any show you see me
do this long rant maybe uh you listen to
it and maybe you're going back and
listen to it that long rant about sugar
Sean I wish I could say it's due to my
Immaculate brain it's not it's due to
happy hippocratum those long rants are
brought to you by happy hippocratum it
allows me just to fire exactly when I
need to it gets me ready to go helps me
just focus and get into the freaking
Zone baby and I only trust one Kratom is
happy hippo so if you've always want to
try Kratom they have pills they have
powders they have gummies they have
their pink lemonade shot which I use
before every single show when I'm doing
stand-up podcasting I do way too many
podcasts so I'm taking a ton of Kratom I
feel fine it's all natural tastes great
do the shot get to work happy hippo.com
promo codes thick boy 20 off for Life
share it with anybody you want to and
you can use that code as many times as
you want your 20 off the best grade them
on the planet
happyhippo.com promo code thick boy 20
off for life now let's get back to the
program
and then without Jermaine Sterling TJ
dillashall
this one was disheartening and I know a
lot of people are upset at TJ like hold
on
your shoulder popped out 20 times during
camp and he still took this fight
knowing
now there's also another high profile
fighter that did this his name's uh
Manny Pacquiao against probably the
biggest box fight of my lifetime against
Floyd Mayweather and people I think
tried to sue Manny Pacquiao because we
still paid whatever that hundred dollars
for that pay-per-view and he had one arm
in that fight now boxing is different
than MMA if you have one arm in MMA you
[ __ ]
I don't have uh hate for TJ dillash on
the facet here so people why would he
even take the fight well he's what 34 35
36 years old 36.
two of those uh years during this Prime
were taken away from obviously just
finally so because you know he got
busted for EPO by usada so he missed two
years in his prime
and if you listen to last week's show on
why you should root for TJ because the
comeback story and after all the [ __ ]
he's been through like Andy Dufresne
crawling through that [ __ ] he made it to
the other side and they gave him you
know Corey sanderhagen he beat him oh he
didn't beat him doesn't matter
on the scorecard in history they haven't
beat him so he did beat him they get the
title shot
having my background at fighting at UFC
at a high level and I look at TJ and his
age and these injuries and going through
everything
I would have taken the fight too I
because if TJ goes I'm hurt they're
feeling somebody else TJ drops back in
the queue he had another Savage
abandonment maybe it's Cheeto maybe it's
Arnold Allen coming up through the
[ __ ] rankings you're gonna get some
Savage
I don't know if you can get back to this
title shot now
are you going to beat algebra and
Sterling on one arm he'd be tough to
beat on two so your chances of winning
it's a it's a Hail Mary it's a Hail Mary
against the best defense of all time
it's a Hail Mary and you're at your one
yard line and you got to throw the ball
99 yards and you got to pray to God that
somebody does something Michigan Miracle
uh University of Colorado Michael
Westbrook Cordell Stewart type of [ __ ]
but there's a chance
anyone take that chance because he's
never going to get back there and I
um I respect it I respect it I'm not mad
at TJ
um I'm mad that his body didn't hold up
and his shoulder was popping out and a
lot of this is because TJ goes so
goddamn hard in the paint during
training camp
you get most of those injuries all those
residual injuries it all catches up to
you when you go that hard you train as
hard as he does you know his knee injury
I would assume a lot of that was
predicated off the way he came into that
camp the way he was training he's goes
so hard the shoulders fall apart he's
built like the the girl off uh A
Nightmare Before Christmas it's sewn up
right he has all these all these
injuries and all the years of wrestling
at College at uh University of
California Fullerton and then the
training camps and The Ultimate Fighter
and the days that uh Team Alpha Male and
then the days at Dwayne Ludwig's and
Muscle Farm and you know high altitude
and all this [ __ ] finally caught up with
him right and his body's falling apart
because you can't can't run it in sixth
gear no matter what size you are for
that long without some things falling
apart it just so happened that his body
starts to fall apart when he's finally
getting a title shot against algeman
Sterling so for all those haters out
there if Tj dillashall going how dare
you do this to us you know this isn't
the fight that we deserve and we we paid
for this put yourself in teach issues
father of three I think now businesses
took two years away from the sport
because he got you know he got busted
you have all this narrative you have all
this [ __ ] and I would be willing to bet
if he stepped away and they tossed in
somebody else he's never gonna get back
there so you're gonna do the best you
can unfortunately
Al Jermain students pretty damn good and
no matter what I think it's fair to say
that Al Jermaine Sterling is the best
bandwid on the planet even TJ dilshaw
with one arm it'd be a tough fight for
him there's a reason he was a dog so you
can't take anything against al Jermaine
and I I don't think there should be a
asterisk on this fight going well Al
Jermaine beat him on one arm how's your
man also eat Peter yon yeah no he didn't
okay dude he didn't but no matter how
you feel about it in the record books
and the judge's eyes all that matters
you and your buddy sitting around the
couch eating potato chips and drinking
beer scored it for Peter Young doesn't
matter I'll Jermaine beat him he's the
best in the world he just beat TJ
Dillashaw but only had one arm algeman
can't do anything about that so he did
what he did and he absolutely [ __ ]
Molly [ __ ] TJ with one arm it wasn't even
a fight right
so he's a co-main event so that co-main
event in the main event I thought were
gonna be the best fights on the card uh
the sugar Shaw one I thought sugar was
at maybe gonna land some money and get
them out of there early I thought if we
went to decision period I was probably
gonna lose uh I wish the sugar Sean
fight was five rounds I think it was
five rounds sugar would have finished
them
and if only sugar Shawn's fans were like
the Diaz Bros fans
we're I'm not sitting here trying to
validate why sugar won I don't have to I
wouldn't have to do that but I feel like
you have to do that on this Monday
morning because all the [ __ ] online
so
if
nicotine kid here if uh sugar Shawn had
an ideas fan base or Nick Diaz fan base
remember when Nick Diaz fought Leon
Edwards and got dominated so for the
last 30 seconds of the fifth round he
landed some the whole narrative was man
if that was 30 more seconds Nate would
have won that was the complete narrative
there was no other narrative his fan
base is so loud and so rabid that they
just went nuts going man 30 more seconds
that fight's over even though he
dominated he got dominated
for four rounds of that fight four
rounds four minutes and 30 seconds
Nate's not even close to winning that
fight lyanna Edwards whooped his ass
but 30 seconds left he takes his eye off
the clock he gets clocked boom say clock
twice whatever he gets clocked he takes
his eyes off the clock he gets clogged
the whole narrative was the idea should
have won that fight if there's only 30
more seconds he'd been out of there it
wasn't how good Leona Edwards looked
none of that that was not the net of any
facet because Leon Edwards fan base
isn't as loud or as massive as Nate Diaz
neither sure Sean's
so now so now we're dealing with this
we're dealing with he didn't win that
fight this but if he had that crazy fan
base like Nate if that was Nate you guys
would be foaming at the dick to validate
Nate winning that fight and how he won
that fight was even close there's no
robbery blah blah blah can't see him in
the title shot you guys will be making
up Nate's champ 209 he's the champ champ
all this [ __ ] everybody does when
any fighter has a massive fan base even
though it's not real it's not justified
these guys with these rabbit fan bases
paint the narrative the loudest online
none of that's real
now that's real what's real is sugar one
what's real is Leon Edwards one right
that's all that matters that's all the
UFC cares about
I've heard some quote unquote experts in
the field go
you know sugar Sean if he's looking nice
but like if I get some holes to fill
I'll take one more fight and then go for
a title shot no what are you out of your
[ __ ] mind no no the UFC's put a
rocket ship on Sugar's back he's already
there you can justify him fighting for a
title right now because he's just beat
the number one bent weight in the world
named Peter Young he beat him they beat
him no matter how you paint the picture
he beat him there's no other direction
to go but a title shot you get past that
Russian [ __ ] nightmare Peter John you
hit a title then the rules dim the rules
all right let's take a little break I'm
sure you guys could use a little break
out there while you're driving to work
maybe driving home from work you listen
to that home and you're just like man my
brain's a little foggy I'm not firing
all cylinders I wish I could form better
sentences like Joe Rogan I wonder what
he uses I'm letting you in a little
secret a little trick of the trade for
the podcast with comedians out there
that you guys always listen to they're
on the best nootropics on the planet
they trust one brand one brand only it's
on it onit.com
you get 10 off the best Frick and
nootropic on the planet we're talking
about Alpha Brain helps you get in that
flow State all right and it's proven
they've done many many tests to prove
that's the best nootropic on the planet
if you don't want to order it and help
your boy out and you
go to your local Walmart and go ahead
and pick it up all right here's the best
thing Alpha Brain and on it they're so
sure you're gonna love Alpha Brain if
you don't love it it's risk-free you get
your money back no questions asked give
them two weeks you're gonna resend your
freaking money and you can keep it how
about that that's how confident on it
and I am of Alpha Brain you have no
reason not to try it also if you're a
little you know worried about caffeine
stuff like that it's caffeine free so
you don't need energy drinks you don't
need coffee you'll need any of that
stuff it's caffeine free getting the
Zone best nootropic on the planet we're
talking about Alpha Brain from on it and
you can save 10 off not just Alpha Brain
but the entire audit site whether it's
freaking multivitamins protein powders
elk bars you want some workout equipment
say less you save 10 off by going to
audit.com
but also try the best nootropic on the
planet for 10 off shows up at your door
audit.com shop 10 off now let's get back
to the program
so in that co-main event Main Event
those were two fights I thought were
gonna go They're Gonna Be Barn burners I
thought Dana was going to be giving out
a bunch of bonuses he's gonna have to
figure out man those are such great
fights back and forth I'm giving both
them by the night performance of the
night right boy was I wrong I'll
Jermaine absolutely Molly [ __ ] TJ with
one arm and Islam makachev who I don't
mind coming in here on Monday morning
when last Monday and I'm finding a kid I
bet Brian Callum that Charles Oliver was
going to win
I was under the assumption that
I've only heard how good he is from his
training partners and his coaches
I've seen it I'm seeing the best
lightweight on the planet I haven't seen
it until you show me I'm not willing to
co-sign that Frank mayor goes I agree I
like Charlesville liver in the fight I
think most MMA heads one of the
impression that Charles Oliveira is so
dangerous for 25 minutes if Islam's just
going to go in there wrestle him he's
gonna have his hands full
even though Javier Mendez Josh Thompson
khabib everyone wants to tell us no he's
the best to ever do it Josh Thompson
last yeah last two weeks ago two
weekends ago when I was in San Jose
doing shows on tour the oh he thick tour
which I'm in Calgary this Thursday we
had a show Friday because Thursday has
five tickets left so we had a show on
Friday next week I'm in San Antonio and
then Houston right and then I end uh the
month in Milwaukee and it goes
Providence Rhode Island but the point is
I'm in Calgary San Antonio Texas and I'm
sorry San Antonio and Houston coming up
and Calgary this week's Calgary but I
was in San Jose and Josh come to the
show comes with Rich child shout out to
Rich Channel my favorite people on the
planet but
when I saw Josh and I know obviously
he's biased he's the AK guys team
captain AKA I go dude Islam Charles
how's he get how how's Islam get it done
and he goes oh walks through him easy
fight easy fight he's ever had one take
out your [ __ ] money is I'm telling
you I see the guy in training him I go
Josh you talking about practice
Javier Menace is best of all time you
guys talking about practice
his resume it's not that impressive
who's he beat that was my thing even the
count who's he beat I'll bet you two
grand on and you know I've lost all this
money and told my agent bet all this
money on him he's not talking to me
right now point is
Islam is who everyone said he is the
guy's [ __ ] good no is he good he's
great he made it look easy it was not a
tough fight for him I think the most
surprising thing and if you're not an
Islam fan what you're gonna have to deal
with is not only is he a splash of
khabib on the ground I think he's
definitely could be but hate the
comparison of khabib obviously they're
like brothers and khabib's father who I
think should be the narrative on this
UFC 280 card is the Father's plan he
took these two young boys who were best
friends who grew up like brothers in
that training room in Dagestan Karen
rocks up a mountain wrestling goats or
the hell they're doing he took these two
young boys
and
arguably
out of them from nothing made the two
best lightweights to ever [ __ ] do it
from Dagestan not a giant place not
known for their UFC champions
he has the first day of staying champion
of all time khabib some are used the
best of all time I would fight back on
that but there's argument there
and now he has another champion in Islam
he said they're both going to be champs
this was the father's plan how that guy
even though he's passed away which is
such a shame we'll use more people like
him but the narrative that this dad took
these two young dagestanian boys
and creating moldum into the best to
ever do it you know what the [ __ ]
chances of that is
if someone came up to that Dad I'm sure
somebody did if somebody came up to that
Dad when those two boys were five years
old six years old and they go what man
these two uh they're pretty good huh
what's the plan he's like excuse me of
the plan they're the best two light
weights in the UFC of all time they're
gonna dominate they're gonna dominate
both of them get the [ __ ] out of it
maybe one would be tough pops both
that's your plan that's father's plan
are you out of your mind yes I'm not
you'll see what's the odds two of them
not one khabib doing his thing not his
son who's put all his effort into
both of them
both of them
dominate
and here's what's going to hurt your
feelings if you're not a dagostanian fan
or you're not Islam fan he's going to do
it for a long time his style
is predicated and structured in a way
that he doesn't take a lot of damage he
doesn't take a lot of risk and there's
some monsters come through those through
the ranks there's some [ __ ] young
lines coming through the ranks problem
is if you're not an Islam or dakistanian
fan you don't like his fighting style
the way he's programmed he doesn't take
a lot of risk and he dominates in every
aspect of mixed martial arts on the feet
he's light years spelling khabib on the
ground maybe he's a notch below oh cool
so he's just a slight Notch below the
best to ever do it when it comes to
grappling I'll take that
and this khabib's Dad the dad plant
father's plan worked out to a [ __ ]
tea
it got a little it never got dice he
could be right I guess the Michael
Johnson fight
the Conor fight he struggled a little
bit but he still dominated both those
gentlemen in all retrospect and then
with uh uh Islam right he had the one
fight he gets knocked out in cool
leading up to this I thought Josh
Thompson's out of his mind I thought
Javier Mendez without his mind I think
khabib was just drinking the Islam
Kool-Aid I know he knows a thing or two
about fighting but still it's like your
brother of course you're gonna be biased
goddamn with these guys right that
[ __ ] is bad
that's a bad man and Stephen A Smith
says that is a bad man I know how you
can beat him
just damn good at striking two doesn't
really get hit a lot
Charles Oliver landed some good punches
I was not Islam's toughest fight they
were right he walked through them
he walked through him they fight a
hundred times he wins 99.
Charles could land a jumping knee of
[ __ ] spinning elbow something that'd
be this one win but
Islam shows up in the right frame of
mind he's being Charles delivered at 99
out of a hundred times that's a tough
pill to swallow for you Brazilians out
there but that's what it is
islamachev is a real deal and what's
brilliant what's absolutely brilliant
and the UFC loves this
is they have a gentleman named Alex
volkanovski sitting cage side who fans
himself going to 155. he's talked about
the super fight Islam wins the fight
he calls out volkonovsky Volk
volkanovsky's cage side no he does he
call him out they're aware that there's
a UFC pay-per-view in Perth Australia so
he goes hey vocalasi once you get in
here you fence yourself you're ranked
number one pound-for-pound goat in the
world right pound number one fire in the
world I'm the best lightweight in the
world you want to come up here let's
fight not only
for volcanoci's title the lightweight
title but let's fight for the pound for
pound title as well so you have three
big titles on the line voganasi wants to
do it he's cage side they get in there
they know the lay of the land with the
big Pay-Per-View come up in Perth they
let's do it in Perth bogonaccos let's do
it the UFC has no other choice to make
that fight that is the fight they've
structured it they have the promo there
they did the promo on the mic
volkanasi's in there they face off
that's Signed Sealed Delivered the UFC's
probably work on it as we speak that's
mache's next fight no matter what
happens Jesse on fire was saying and I
definitely value his opinion he goes uh
if Chandler gets done against poy like
in a big fashion that's the fight I
disagree I disagree it's very rare you
have a guy as dumb as Alexander
volkonovsky in a weight class below who
wants to come up right it's very rare
it's perfect timing it's just the
perfect timing and it just happens they
have the big pay-per-view in Perth it
just so happens Islam called him out and
also
from what I've heard from very close
sources to Islam is kind of the knock on
Islam was he doesn't show up when the
lights are the brightest he doesn't like
other interviews all the attention he
just wants to do his job get the [ __ ]
out so sometimes it can be a lot for me
to fight to his true potential but if he
does you have the best lightweight to
ever do it well if you've seen his
demeanor while he's walking out to the
cage in Abu Dhabi when he's walking out
there you realize pretty loose
the lights didn't get to him oh [ __ ] he
passed the test
oh wow the one kind of caveat there if
if the lights are too bright he's not
going to show up he showed up that's out
the window you won't hear it from me
anymore
Jesus Christ what a performance
even that being the performance of the
night I'm sure they gave him the uh
performance bonus I don't know how they
decided so Fight the Night O'Malley
Peter Young performance tonight Mike
Jeff and Mohammed they nailed that all
day every day
they got it right
so even with Islam completely Molly
whopping walking through Charles de
Lavere like acai on a hot summer day in
[ __ ] Rio
and calling out
the pound-for-pounder more guy in the
world Alexander volcanovski and he was
cage slide and he gets in there and they
face off
I told you guys The Narrative is still
sugar Shawn O'Malley who's the biggest
star on the card he's the topic of
conversation right now good or bad he's
I don't care I didn't say it was gonna
be good or bad I just said if sugar Sean
pulls this off no matter what happened
in the co and Main Event Suga will be
the top of conversation on Monday here
we are
what can you do shout out to everyone
that one man what a freaking card man
what a freaking card
love it love it best sport in the world
best born world for this reason
I I think some of the stuff on sugar
Shawn too
and I keep going back to Sugar but it's
important I think some of the stuff on
sugar too is the media and the fan base
you know and even when I heard this
fight it was now it's like Jesus Christ
why would they take that fight what a
bad matchup and then you take your bias
out for it and I love shooting he knows
this and I text him he's a buddy even
all that said once I took all that away
and then you break the fight they're
like it's not terrible I didn't see how
sure you can win this fight out of the
top five it man even though it's Peter
yawn this Russian Savage I can see how
sugar is going to win this fight I can
see him getting it done
I can see how he gets it done but if
you're not if you don't have the
the perspective of how sure you can win
and you were like oh he's just gonna get
annihilated he's gonna go in there I bet
it's not even a fight I bet he gets
[ __ ] crushed and then after that
first round and even the dudes who do
the BTS Sports who my favorites my
absolute favorites with Bisping I love
them they're my favorite the two British
blokes they're my favorites even they
said they're saying K side and their
media media's row and after the first
round they all looked around went holy
[ __ ] I'll get a sugar shot oh my God oh
this we gotta fight on all the things to
me if nobody thought I was gonna be a
fight if you're not a sugar fan everyone
went oh oh my God so I think that has
something to do with all this backlash
of sugar right now where everyone was
surprised at just not only did he show
up
but he won not only did he show up but
he won rounds not only did he show up
but you guys thought you can get
absolutely starched and that first round
even if you're a sugar hater you went ah
you couldn't there's no way after the
first round you looked around went Peter
yawn all day easy that was the easy one
right Peter Young dominated man that was
such an easy round for Peter Young
nobody said that so I think part of this
backlash is everyone like oh [ __ ] we
have a fight on our hands and everyone's
surprised like what's happening here and
it's kind of skewed your vision on how
you scored the fight because because now
you're just looking at the fight going
oh sugar yeah he's like in his ass what
but it but you need to go back and watch
it and not only is he liking his ass
what beating his ass on the feet beating
his ass
significant strikes being his ass
Damage Done he's beating his ass
except for the second round first and
third beating his ass
dim the rules damn facts
great card what else you got Jen all
well also over the weekend was the John
lineker for Brock right yeah contest uh
accidental growing shot that actually
worse that actually broke his cup Jesus
just pretty crazy I'll show you the
actual okay cup from like Dick's
Sporting Goods is one of those steel
Muay Thai can you imagine if it was
steel and they broke it that'd be insane
here we go
fight in the bantamweight division
and then low two lows shame is because
that andrage was doing work too he's
doing work I mean lineker did pretty
well too he hit him with some really big
shots but that guy was just faster
younger accurate yeah so it's a no
contest the next big one is November
18th yeah somewhere yeah
I believe it is November
yep Amazon versus Lee that's uh
angelie's brother who's champion mm-hmm
November 18th and November 19th
alrighty going back to um the TJ doshaw
shoulder thing so
I guess TJ told well everyone knows now
that in retrospect that he did have this
issue for a while it popped out over 20
times he told the ref ahead of time that
hey my most likely my shoulder's gonna
pop out so we're gonna put it back in
don't stop it yeah and then Dana White
was saying that he he had no idea that
his shoulder had issues and he's not
really and he should have told us or
something like that but it's tough
because he tells you he probably pulled
you're done already he's not the main
you know he's not the co-main event this
huge card probably not getting title
shot again I can see how people are
upset at TJ but if you put yourself in
TJ's shoes
you know at his age I'm with TJ and
listen I would be one bet I don't know
who you know I don't see social media I
would assume no Elite fighter was like I
can't believe TJ took the fight every
single fighter worked their [ __ ] salt
would step up and take that fight
especially if you're in TJ shoes every
single fighter and it's not on the UFC
you know the commission they don't know
you know they don't check every joint
like there's like any injuries reporting
like nope like cool to check your heart
rate to check your blood pressure they
do like a weird eye test you're good to
go nobody it's so easy to get out of
there and he looked like he looked at me
in really great shape however the one
thing I was wondering about is like the
if he's telling the ref like it's most
likely going to pop out isn't it I don't
want the rough to stop it's not in the
ref's job though okay like the ref isn't
gonna go up to Dana but okay you don't
teach okay you got the commission
volcano TJ like the ref is like oh okay
you know good to know I got like uh
Travis Brown if I told the ref I'm like
I messed my neck up in Camp my neck if I
if I hit on I'm [ __ ] man just be aware
of that if you see my neck you know
compromise position like probably I told
him probably stop the fight yeah that's
there's the main teacher
I got [ __ ] to do my neck's all [ __ ] up
so if it gets worse definitely stop this
thing
yeah
well that's I think it's smarter for
your life but uh okay so Charles
Oliveira he released a statement after
the loss
and it's not that long so
he goes I haven't slept yet because
naturally I've been reflected on
everything that happened thank you thank
you so much to all the people that have
sent me both positive and negative
messages the criticism is part of this
crazy sport I'll go home now dedicate
myself to train and Conquer once again
thank you to everyone that texted me and
then he goes on to say something like at
the very end is what I thought was
interesting because thank you so much I
will dedicate myself to return stronger
and Conquer to please everyone so it's
like he's doing it for you know his
country I get it people there's a lot of
pressure on tube in the face of uh MMA
especially face of UFC Brazil you know
there's a lot of pressure that comes
that and he's a superstar out there like
it's different than being a champ here
it just is Brazil really honors their
gym and stuff like that I think for
um Charles Oliveira the next move would
be
um I I think Darius Darius uh Charles
Oliver is the fight to make Charlie if
Darius beats him for the love of I know
everything's holy give him a title shot
yeah but I think if they want to you
know they're not getting a tall shot
next because you know Mark Jeff and
homeboy uh he's gonna tie that up so it
and when there's super fights like that
it holds the the division up but I think
if you want to make it very clear you
know he could do Darius for Charles
Oliver on that Perth card yeah that'd be
sick neither one of them are injured you
know he could do that
and this I thought was really cool this
is his team uh with Oliveira during his
weight cut and there's like a gazillion
people around him they're all
essentially looking like this train who
who are the haters that don't have the
blonde hair done who's not drinking like
maybe they're allergic who knows but
there's so many people that did their
hair blonde that's cool that's so cool
man and I'll play this audio for your or
this video real quick too
20 made weight
see so this makes more sense when it
comes to his uh
kind of explanation to what silent you
down I'm doing this for like just such
rabbit support yeah like friends and
family and they all believe in them and
think about they all fly out there the
knob like it's a lot of pressure man you
feel like you let everybody down yeah no
he didn't you know he fought Islam it's
all good
yeah he fight a killer yeah the killer
yeah
um you saw this video by now I'm
guessing I haven't seen it okay Jessie
on fire when we were headed back uh I
think from my show could you stay for
the show when we're headed back to the
hotel he was like man how about uh see
original I thought he was talking I was
just been paying attention I was like
staring out the window looking at
Mormons in Salt Lake but um I thought he
was saying mock Jeff got into it with a
teammate oh my God what teammate fights
with the one that just won the World
Championship so it's Hamza gonna fight
with one of khabib's teammates yeah Abu
Bakr and the market made of who fought
on the card and won his side all right
so but I guess there's a long history
something happened where it actually
involves hamzan hamzan kadirov you know
the crazy dictator dude uh I guess he
was doing some sort of live feed and
then he said something about khabib and
then hamzat said something like don't
worry I'll I'll tear him up or we'll
tear them up like kind of you know going
against khabib and so khabib's cousin
wrote something to him and then it
started it was like years I think it was
years ago wow but eventually um so they
saw each other here today first and then
uh it's way smaller right uh not too
much smaller I'll show you this video
real quick though you'll see I'll show
you which ones are which and this is
yeah he's bald with the polo on the and
then where's
pause it yeah yeah who which one's which
so this is Oh I thought Hamza was bald
in the blue polo dude
who's the guy the bald guy who's the
next UFC champion the bald guy there so
there's hom that in the black shirt
black cat yeah and then where's uh okay
this is Abu bakar
[Music]
oh he's calling him out so they're
actually holding hands right here so far
more than what I asked
[Music]
man what's the main video yeah so but
then they're they're referencing their
beef from before like way back the whole
thing where you know his cousin's
defending khabib and then he's probably
like hey but I know what you said like
let's not you know it comes up for like
a few and then put in chest in or
whether they speak and then it was on
yep those are two tough gentlemen indeed
but afterwards they squashed the beef I
guess khabib had to interview
intervene and so did that guy oh that's
good man yeah and then you can see them
in a video later on what's that homs
like that always look like he's hunting
even though he's a you know the
president of uh I don't know what he is
he's a dictator oh yeah he's a dictator
he always just looks like he's on a
hunting trip yeah he's always in
camouflage
so they so they they face time now like
Hey we're buddies I guess so and khabib
also intervened uh there's a video with
them all together so it's all good now I
mean yeah khabib tells you to [ __ ]
tighten up you better tighten up and
then also do you hear what it could be
told uh Mike Jeff too
Where'd I see this at
I saw an interview khabib told mock Jeff
I guess it was maybe during the press
conf something like that and he was like
yeah you have two weeks off
you get two weeks off he became champ
cool but now the work starts like if
you're gonna be the grace of all time
now the work starts like we have work to
do it's just that mindset like Jesus
Christ
Savages yeah I take a hard month off
I've been Fiji I've been Dubai at Dick's
getting all out it'd be crazy a lot of
people showed up there to the the fights
at Abu Dhabi like uh Steve Harvey was
there you saw Steven Seagal there I saw
Steven Seagal makes sense but uh Steve
Steve Harvey's around and Steve Harvey
if you notice he was taxing the entire
fight it drives me oh really it's Steve
Harvey you look like a giant walrus
you're just texting the entire fight
you have ringside tickets to this
caliber fighting you're gonna chat who
are you taxing
if sticks and your daughter I understand
and what's this just was this what's all
them together the Men in Black that's uh
abubakar and there's hanza right there
so everyone's cool and then the leader
could be just in the middle like come
get some yeah
and so this I thought was funny too so
Paula Costa
wrote this on his Instagram this is the
reason he thought they fought
he put Paul's the best looking fighter
and best middleweight don't be mad he
stole your had Gourmet Chen Chen it
looks way better on him so I had to
really the the beard that's what I was
okay I was trying to figure out how to
do a deep dive to figure out what he
meant he stole your he meant to say
don't be mad he stole your hat because
you know uh comes I took off his hat
yeah so I guess he made a reference to
stealing your hat I don't know if it has
anything to do with the Jake Paul stuff
but he goes Gourmet Chen Chen I'm like
what the hell does that mean so he
posted this a while ago
this is what Nate Diaz
with Jake Shields he goes look at those
guys Jay Shields Nate Diaz Nate is a
real gangster not chimaya if he lives in
Sweden with a couple nerds he's just a
gourmet Chen Chen cake so he meant he
met a gourmet Chechen
can you call him Gourmet because you
know how he gained a ton of he couldn't
lose weight by a lot so you're saying
like a gourmet like someone that loves
him call back deep call back
um yeah and this I thought was
interesting too so you know so Dana
White stopped up stopped the press
conference because of the backs you know
behind the stage or behind the scenes
brawl so this one he kind of said it was
like whatever this is what Fighters do
when you talk now I'm sorry it was funny
what do I even say about that happens
especially with harms that it happens uh
what explains why husband was sitting in
typical section dedicated for UFC
fighters he was sitting on our side I
didn't even know Hamza was coming
tonight he was he was invited here by
Abu Dhabi so the seats behind me here in
Abu Dhabi are owned by Abu Dhabi and
then that's what we do here that's what
we do this is a rough business mean
things are said sometimes guys get into
it it's our job you see to make sure
that kind of stuff doesn't happen we
weren't right on it and couldn't stop it
from happening but we got in there these
things happen when you get 800 alpha
males and females on a contract
sometimes they cross paths at events
these things happen doesn't bother me or
hurt my feelings or any of that stuff I
would never cancel weighing in over a
fight we handle it and move on I made up
that stop lightweight but you get what
I'm saying yeah so he's kind of like ah
whatever happens it's not a big deal yep
yeah I thought that was really
interesting he said chestnutes are gonna
chasten you man what do you want me to
do and this uh is essentially Dana White
confirming that Conor McGregor is not in
the testing pool that's why he's not
being tested I don't know usually you
have to be retired right to not be
tested you have to notify me I can get
tested and get tired that sucks it's
it's getting murky water yeah whatever
yacht Conor's on the waters are murky as
far as the drug testing goes I wonder if
he just pulled out he said I was like
I'm gonna be doing something to recover
don't be testing me so I'm gonna have to
back out this is like all right we'll
make sure you don't say you're retired
they wouldn't scare the fans and then
once you're fully recovered come back
into the testicle make sure you're clean
that's what's going it's it's very
sketchy it's very rare so I'll play this
uh so he's out six months
Jon Jones you know he's not fighting
December either like two they're big
boys man it's frustrating okay let me
place real quick this is from anime
junkie reporter it's that girl I forgot
her name pharah something okay
uh speaking of usada it appears on the
database that Conor McGregor hasn't been
uh tested this year would he have to
complete six months before he can
compete yeah
so he can't return until six months
right all right thank you you know
what's funny is if this didn't become
transparent
kind of Spain for six months I know how
that has come out he's like yeah
you're right he's like yep good eye [ __ ]
that's their best escape for like why
he's not being tested yeah yeah yeah he
pulled himself out of it oh so he's
retired nobody said that I know
and this is Connor's reaction to I know
Connor's the best at making himself
relevant during other people's success
right and it's one of the reasons you
love him also one of the reasons you
hate them it's tough too with this
narrative and no you listen I love Conor
McGregor you guys know there's some big
Dublin dick right on Connor but
you know here this one nice fight nice
performance I have built all the tools
to beat his style Now versus before
experience for [ __ ] face breaking shots
from clinch baby brain battle shots from
the bottom the rest of my repertoire
used nose steel left leg Cannon backhand
wrist control I I just I don't I know
you so you cut to 55. I'm Gonna Catch 55
but you've been off how long you had to
sign a drug testing which might be a
benefit but you know these yachts and
these Gucci sheets you're gonna sign up
to face mochachev yeah I mean yeah this
is his thing of course he does this and
I expected this was just like man the
thought of shutting down the system of
fighting with my own developed system is
quite intriguing to me who whoever of
them against is not personal it's a
skill evaluation a fight even through
generations the imams amateurs a war of
attrition to to the box of the system to
hurt the style of fighting guys I'm
telling you bro is a [ __ ] jocks fat
mouth shut your mouth you've done
nothing tonight except go against
father's wishes and run on it's not
Father's plan com completed yet pal you
know your people know when they talk
about you so he's bringing up khabib's
Dad right now too which is like man yeah
it's a it's yeah now I mean to kind of
Defense you know he did uh do the best
against khabib but that's how Dominic
khabib was even though you know maybe
you've kind of two rounds won but you
know still dominate you know he got beat
for the majority of the fight but that's
how good khabib was like yeah I kind of
didn't do terrible that's how [ __ ]
good khabib was my my two old belts on
two little ticks this fight does ten
buys oh I just that's what Connor
talking about Islam and volcano but
again this is going to see makes him
relevant right people like like Twain
does this stuff
but it starts same thing with John it's
like John and Kim and Connor who I love
knows khabib doesn't do this right and
he doesn't care it's never been his
thing but with John and Connor it's like
whenever things are getting going right
they sent out a tweet right and they and
they deleted it and stuff it keeps them
relevant in the in the
Zeitgeist of MMA fighting right but it's
also like
you gotta fight fellas like at a certain
point if you're not fighting I don't
care like you guys gotta fight
eventually you just gotta fight
otherwise I don't care what you Tweet
now if the year and you have injuries
whatever and with John like going to
heavyweight taking the air okay two
years
whatever I don't care anymore yeah like
tweets like these I think are just kind
of just the funny ones that's just how
to do this thing yeah the other one
going against the dad the ish yeah
oh yeah what do you think as far as uh
the odds if when I was the odd maker I
would have Islam probably a two to one
favorite maybe three to slight three to
one like minus
300
here we have DraftKings markets minus
400 favorite The Comeback four to one
Underdog yeah yeah and volcanovski plus
300.
that makes sense
um okay so I just saw this pop up
recently to Dan Hardy he was on a
podcast and talked he was saying stuff
about
the Nate Diaz shamaya fight and Dana
White like I'll I'll show him and Danny
got into it yes it was like he's just
mad because he got aggressive with a
woman then Dan hires a cow dude I didn't
do anything yeah he was like first of
all the woman which all her co-workers
know and listen Dan Hardy's not a liar
but Dan hog is like first of all uh all
the all her you know
um payers all know what kind of person
she is she was taking work away from me
and I call it out in front of everybody
embarrassed her he was like and then you
know I don't know what she told uh Dana
but I didn't get to express my version
of the story to Dana so I'll hear it
it's her size and so the next time I'll
get fired yeah so Dan Hardy put out
mystery and a woman at Dana White
question mark how dare excuse me of such
a thing which is not the way to go if
it's not true God my God damn it Dana
you know this is me too movement [ __ ]
why would you you why would you go down
that alley man clear proof that you were
told lies about what happened and why
they steered all the all the Dan Hardy
Quest away from you
yeah responding that
um so anyways let's skip the Nate Diaz
channel thing it was that was just more
of Dan Hart's saying like they they knew
they were [ __ ] up by putting that
match together and then later on they're
like he feels as if they did something
Shady to make that fight not happen
I'm like we're I guess they knew yeah
with uh Nate and uh hamzat that was that
they can
I don't give a flying [ __ ] and somehow I
became the face of this conspiracy it
has nothing to do it
I truly think that they the UFC
overplayed their hand there they thought
you know they're gonna make an example
of Nate and give them homs on his
terrible matchup they thought that was
going to sell because Nate's fan base
and you know I said if you're not Nate
fan the way you you fight this is don't
buy the pay-per-view it was such a
mismatch it wasn't trending how they
thought they were going to lose money
like we had to do something here I got
to that truly think they were like we
gotta switch this up people aren't
feeling this also not to mention that as
you know Fighters retired fires are
coming up with these lawsuits and trying
to sue us this didn't give them more
fuel to fire to come after us down the
road like if Nate retires and it's like
look what you guys did to me you know
this just shows yeah this kind of
receipts it shows this trail of them you
know really really you know screwing
Fighters over so I think like the smart
thing to do here man is switch it up
switch it up and that's what they did
yeah that's well that's and I'm glad
they did so he put imagine really bad
Hood straight away it had been a cast
shadow of the UFC we've been all over
the news in a negative way it would have
made us all feel uncomfortable because
we knew it was happening I agree it was
fortunate the MMA got shined down on us
that day but I also feel like there was
some meddling in the background to make
sure that didn't happen because I think
the closer the fight got the more the
UFC realized how much they were going to
bury themselves if Nate got hurt
couldn't agree more
then he also said that he believes that
when Calvin kater and Max Holloway
fought you know cater was getting pretty
damn messed up during that yeah it was
awful so Dan Hardy believes there's a
video that the UFC made that made it
look like Dana White was really like
concerned about cater and wanted to go
to the hospital and this that but he
feels like it was sort of staged it
wasn't like a real video I'll show you
the clips real quick
so I'll play parts of these
guys
and then he goes back behind the scenes
here
so much [ __ ] punishment this fight
I'm freaking out a little bit man I
don't know this this reminds me of the
kind of a fight where the fight's over
and he walks them back and [ __ ] dies
yeah and and I think that [ __ ] Herb
Dean should have stopped it in the
fourth round yeah I don't play too much
because it's UFC stuff but he's
basically saying that he thinks okay why
is the camera on them so perfectly why
they miked up so perfectly to where you
can hear all that stuff he could be like
he's really doing is he shooting his
show uh yeah he's doing I think the
problem yeah the caveat there is right
this again there's confirmation bias so
whoever you don't like you can find
certain things where you can confirm
something and maybe I and I don't know I
don't want to entertain his content but
um not because I don't like him I just I
don't have the time I don't and I also
don't care right I'm trying to make my
own content so I I don't know if Dana's
done this before where he's shown
concern for fives or not but if you want
confirmation bias you can play that game
like look at this [ __ ] I don't know
if it's [ __ ] I would assume enjoy
the people in that Arena were concerned
about Calvin kater like that you know
that was a bad thing yeah we all were so
for the president you'll see be like hey
man this ain't good this is bad and
maybe shooting a show because I did see
Dan Thomas there and met Sarah then
shoot the show yeah you know I I it's
tough to say it was stage you know that
doesn't seem like a thing Dana would do
you know it's also the right thing to do
I don't think he's saying like they I
made everything up I think they made it
look like they're just shooting Dana
White and them looking like Dana White's
really like you know worried about stuff
like instead of not shooting him like it
with the microphone on him and you know
the camera's perfectly placed they
wanted him to sound like that and look
like it like a guy who's really caring
about so this is Dana responding was
like I can't I can't tell you we've
never staged anything ever
um
uh that's another thing too like come on
yeah I'm sure wow uh we have a
documentary that we filmed during covert
that's why I was miked I've never been
miked I was miked because of that yeah
maybe they're doing the doc because
they're the only major sports League to
continue during the pandemic which you
know hats off to them for pulling that
off uh are you talking about when I was
talking about let's get them straight to
the hospital do you know how many fights
a week I say that to the UC Chief
business office officer Hunter Campbell
and the Dr Davidson shot Dr Davidson no
interviews no nothing that guy goes
straight to the hospital everybody
should have been concerned about Calvin
kater that night
yeah again there's a lot of confirmation
biased
he was mic'd up for a documentary that
fight just so happened it was a really
rough one that's a tough sell for me
yeah I love Dan Hardy and I I'm down to
go wherever he wants to steer this ship
with him
um but that one's tough it was so tough
I mean yeah I think the headlines made
it seem as if Dan Hart is saying that
everything's like fake but it's just
more him pointing out why do they have
to have a perfect shot of Dana White
they want to they want to make Dana
White look like a guy that cares about
people more you know I I do think Dana
cares but I also I do I think he cares
about uh Fighters certain Fighters okay
he does he He does care about certain
Fighters I know that for a fact another
one's he doesn't go flying [ __ ] about
and then certain times as a business
owner
you know he does have to protect his
business even though he's not the
majority owner but he's still the face
of the company so yeah man he's like hey
man they let this thing go and that kid
dies in the back we're [ __ ] yeah so
it's more of that that's more of
business concerns also if you look at
over all the content things ever put out
I would imagine the majority of it is
going to pay him in a good light so you
can Nick you know take things and for
confirmation bias like well look at this
how fake does this look it's like yeah
tough sell for me
all right um a few fight announcements
so Dana White mentioned that Colby
Covington and Hamza he wants that on the
undercard or you know maybe a co-main or
something for the Edwards Camaro card
my God I'm coming I'm more excited for
Colby versus hamzat than I am Leon
Edward tomorrow three
I think tomorrow's gonna do work now hom
thought Kobe that's a truck and fight
son
yeah that's gonna be a great fight we're
gonna learn a lot about homside in that
fight which I'm excited for
and this one is that Landing card it's
February I believe
oh no March London March man February
and March are getting thick it's
February I think February is that Perth
pay-per-view they have Islam and
is your main event they have this and if
tomorrow and Leon Edwards
insane and this was pretty interesting
too Patty Penwood and Jared Gordon at
UFC 282 December it's a good step up and
come to this for Pali Patty because
Jared uh Gordon is a real vet you know
he's legit yeah so this will probably be
have his hands full again I and I love
these fights for these young fighters in
their career we're gonna find a lot out
about Patty now
and Robert Whittaker versus Paulo Casa
on that Perth card
284 oh so this is later than 284.
no never mind February 11th yup February
the same card your main event and the
Deathly co-manager said added yeah
booked
so that's your main event if they can't
figure out the uh but that's a great
Main Event yeah
oh that's a good fight yeah I'm good I
love that fight and then I'm sure you
know about this already too but Bo
Nichols debut his actual UFC debut I
know he got injured you got injured pull
him off I know I don't know what
happened there I talked a little bit
about it on uh
Mania
it's all good yeah and they don't know
if it's gonna be when he comes back if
it's going to be his original opponent
Jamie Pickett or someone else but we'll
find out I guess later this is promotion
plans to rebook the former Nittany line
for UFC 285 and that's in March yeah I
dig that
and this is a real a pretty cool one
from Bellator
they're bringing five of their fighters
to fight ryzen fighters for their New
Year's Eve card so it's going to be
their badass Fighters too AJ McKee
Patricio Pitbull Juan Archuleta kyoji
horoguchi
and then maybe one more hour that's fine
Dan Belcher was bringing over the Heavy
Hitters yeah to fight another
organization yeah
um I just thought I thought this was
already like a known thing but UFC has a
an updated athlete code of conduct where
they're saying that if you're a fighter
you your Camp everyone cannot bet on
your fights if you even bet on yourself
yeah I mean I I thought this was uh
-huh okay I could understand
you know if you're a slight Underdog or
whatever or even if you're a favorite
and you're putting you know 20 G's on
yourself because you think you're starts
the guy
the problem with that is you gotta think
it's an umbrella because a lot of guys
made with their big underdog and they're
putting a ton of money on themselves and
to purposely lose like that's where the
people yeah [ __ ] the losing losing again
it can't be an umbrella where well
they're only about themselves to win no
no no we'll see what's going on here can
have the camp doing it you know
no [ __ ] I figured another news say UFC
says you can't bet on the fights if
you're the UFC no [ __ ] just like the NFL
can't bet on their games
MLB can't bet on themselves
but also even their team are not
teammates but their coaches or whatever
I guess they can't I'm with it yeah no
[ __ ] and now you know DraftKings be
legalized in all states like can't have
it yeah they say gambling is being
legalized a lot more places
this was on uh MMA hour Yuri prashka he
said he went three days without food and
in the Darkness
to confront his demons he only had water
and this is the room right there
I saw this headline which I would never
that sounds like a kid never three days
I couldn't do it how did you sleep have
you see that setup oh yeah it's just a
bed a bed kind of looks pretty comfy
there's some two bugs but I mean it's in
the dark just a real Warrior
I mean put himself in solitary
confinement for them yes the facts of it
just get his mind right yeah just to
find himself
what do you say it's very helpful
there's just you and you know other
people that was my first time when I did
that without food so just with water
it's much more strong when you're
without food
all the process in your body is much
stronger your mind's working a lot and
you have to die here first and three
days four days that's not so much but
I'll use that just to recognize who I am
really and then I can start training
pushing to the next level
wow yeah Savage yeah
um I I think he Molly wops
um Glover Glover for the second time yes
yes
so there were rumors that potentially
Bobby green and Euler latifi were cut
from the UFC because they they were
missing from the roster that's now I
guess debunked
um Bobby green I guess since he's he has
to serve a suspension they just kind of
take you off yeah two years right no no
six months oh six months that's not bad
it was only DHEA it wasn't like you know
popping but then didn't some what
homeboy got kicked off uh the UFC card
like before weigh-ins remember that what
happened to him he was on the undercards
and they literally like he's out and cut
him uh I think that was I think I think
he had another contract yeah he couldn't
get out of his other contract yeah he's
like yo we're not gonna go yeah legal to
deal with this Japanese fire yeah it's
like that heavyweight heavyweight UFC
sign then the manager was like well no I
still own his rights he was like right
forget him yeah so I think that was
iller's uh opponent I think but anyways
alir I guess he uh he knew he had staff
but when he talked the TV's looking
thick he's super wow my God he's thick
he's so strong
but uh so he had staph infection and he
kind of said it during like a the post
five uh interview if I just fight with
staff all the time yeah but he admitted
it so once he admitted it
um the commission said you're gonna be
yeah you're not supposed to be fighting
with staff and admitting it so so he's
I'm not sure how long his suspension now
a lot of guys a lot of Fighters will
fight with staff because the antibiotics
for staff drain you yeah if you remember
um
Roger Gracie he had it and uh it was a
guy looks really slow and his cardio is
awful it wrecked your cardio wrecked
your energy like there's a lot of guys
like I'm just gonna deal with the staff
till I get through the fight and you got
to pray to God it doesn't spread and
then you end up like rest in peace Kevin
Randleman yeah I don't know if you've
ever seen that stat oh it was horrific
if it starts getting the bloodstream
super dangerous but you know again
how many people is this would do that if
you get staff you're not going to take
the antibiotics because you want to get
to the fights you need the money how
many fighters going to fight with one
one arm like TJ Dillashaw like Fighters
are different animals all this backlash
to teaching stuff like that you're not a
professional cage fighter at the highest
level that earns your pace for their
family's mortgage and your food so
before you get all mad and get upset at
TJ you got to realize these guys are Cut
From a Different Cloth that's why you
pay to watch them
the TV staff anyone else here
comic podcaster Joe Blow working at
Starbucks you're going to get
antibiotics uh ruins your cardio cool
oh it doesn't give me energy cool I
don't give a [ __ ] these guys they give a
[ __ ] yeah it's gonna affect their
performance
I think um only difference here is that
when you have staff you can potentially
infect the other person that's why
they're frowning on this yeah it's not
deadly and if you take care of it right
I mean Fighters Jiu Jitsu guys wrestlers
deal with staff their entire lives and
they're very good at it yeah you
mentioned um TJ I heard some like a
little bit of Luke Thomas talking about
it he said that if he knew his shoulder
was that bad his team and everyone
should have stopped him from doing it
because it's going to ruin his career
forever now because he had like multiple
he had two surgeries already like both
shoulders and coming into this to let
him fight it was on the coaches to like
take him off that car it's on the
fighter that's what I'm saying so when
you were pointing out your point it does
seem like TJ is the last straw if he
wants to do it he wants to do it and
they really have to go along with it now
if he gets like knocked out and he's
this young fighter he's fighting the
main event and I wish my team would have
took me to the side I got knocked out
before I was fighting Ben Rothwell and
no gear by Shane Carwin during training
oh yeah I'm talking knocked out and that
was like a week before this should be
like this ain't good you get clipped
you're gonna be [ __ ] but no one said
anything but also if you're gonna you
want to do it you're gonna do it
yes and no if at that time I was a young
fighter you know and I was on this big
win streak that ended up hurt my career
more than helping but in TJ's case you
gotta realized he's 34-35 probably not
going to get his title shots different
title shot's a different animal title
shot I'm not mad that he fought with one
arm the house that's different his age
the injuries who knows if you can get
back there young fight like let's say
Patty had a shoulder injury or sugar
Shawn had a shoulder injury or that
young kid
um that they just signed off Contender
series or bow nickel like you were just
getting started it ain't worth them take
your time get healed heal up bring your
best self to the Octagon these veterans
you don't get a lot of opportunities you
got to fight through it
and it is title shot right so this I
thought was very interesting Tata 5000
is returning again well yeah
he's my favorite you're gonna love this
remember when he fought Kimbo yeah and
then people were like what's this thing
can happen but did you die he's like
yeah I did yeah no I did I didn't do
cardio right and literally died
by the way that was his last fight oh
wow yes I was returning from that you
got that cardio right dude check out his
car he's looking thick right there check
out his stats according to him uh wait
let's go past all this this is what I
thought was uh really funny
works out at the gym two to three hours
a day presses 225 pounds 30 times with
ease and he runs at 4.4 to 4.5 40 yard
dash okay well here's the thing
um definitely run a 4-4 Donna 5000 but
also we got two three times a day or two
three hours a day in the gym I work out
two three hours a day in the gym yeah
yeah standard we all do when we're
competing at a professional level can
bench press 225 30 times how much does
he weighs he's like I don't know three
it's got to be close to 300. not that
impressive but also good for you but
also I assume that uh the one caveat out
of all this is run the four in four four
the guy that timed you or your mom at
times you she's lying to you or she just
don't know how to now listen I'm not
calling a liar I'm saying the person
that's holding the clock's alive and
doesn't know what they're doing it's
missteps there same thing you know just
chabelle Lacy was my future for everyone
was on finding the kids said he ran a
four three or four four and forty oh
spell I'm not calling you a liar I'm
calling you gym coach a lot
yeah
that I thought that was pretty hilarious
and by the way that's his organization
byb extreme and I've looked everywhere
online I can't find what byb means no
Backyard Brawl oh my gosh dude
good stuff man I couldn't find it
anywhere stuff man hey all here's the
other thing you got to be the only 45
year old who runs a 4-4 in the 40. 45 at
300 pounds around four foot bro you
could go walk onto the [ __ ] Georgia
Bulldogs or the Miami Hurricanes a 4 4
45 years old 300 pounds I know go trial
for the Dallas Cowboys
yeah
but it's not his fault it's whoever
timed him right it's just it's his mom
homeless timer [ __ ] them
okay so this I guess when Israel this is
not that new Israel arasana's video of
him doing a Training Method with his
trainers throwing like I think tennis
balls at him and he's dodging that
before yeah so that was that was a
little while ago and then fans did give
him a hard time for it so now Alex
pahaya his next opponent he's mocking
him so I'll show you Israel's thing
first so this is the original video
[Music]
let's just work on Reaction Time clearly
it's not a fight
a slow-mo
so then this is Alex position reaction
drill okay
Alex player is making fun of him here
[Music]
so silly
and just not throwing at him at all God
he's funny man
[Laughter]
it's a lot more than he blindfolds
himself
he's actually pretty funny dude
that's funny
uh this is a little clip on Mikey
musumechi who won the first ever belt
right he won championship for grappling
he's challenging [ __ ] people I'll just
play the clip for you real quick
the funny quote from kabuti said if
[ __ ] was easy to be called Jiu Jitsu so
let's have the [ __ ] guys compete with
the Jiu-Jitsu people let me fight the
top world champion of my weight class in
[ __ ] and let's see which is Superior in
the submission grappling format is that
funny
nicest call out of all time I know uh so
he put that challenge out on October 4th
and I don't know this guy but I just
looked I'll let him speak and he's like
a sample guy same weight class hey guys
so I ran across Mikey musumechi's
Instagram reel calling out the number
one zombies in his wig category he's
currently the one flyweight submission
grappling champion and I'm currently in
a three-way tie for the number one 64 kg
psalmist in the world so the white guy
she's an American 64kg Sports Samba
champion
Mikey I think we should get this done we
just need to talk about the rule set and
when and where
see you on the mat just the two nicest
guys ever trying to prove the points nah
man for Samba I want a real hardcore
Russian dakistani against our boy Mikey
he said he's uh tied top three guys in
Samo yeah badass and these are just some
kicks that were on during during media
day at UFC 280. and since you know about
kicks tell me what you think of these
These are Sean's
valencias
are those sugars yeah
Valencia's one of those dunks
Omar Walmart yeah those are like Italian
brand I don't really mess with those oh
yeah I don't know much about them
how dare Sean not wear his J balance he
already scored them I know but still
killed Abram Abu Dhabi biggest fire your
life and I supported you all right your
boy Deontay Wilder he's now
in a music video This is his song Yes
okay well this makes me here we go
no production is great did you show you
that bathtub with his logo I know
um have you uh have you you watched nine
Day Fiance there's a Nigerian uh he's an
actor and he does music and it sounds
identical and he has this girl she
starts she's like like you know she's
like 60 it's clearly trying to use a
green card to come over here but she has
to fly to Africa and watch this music
video just with all these [ __ ]
they're gonna fight it's not gonna work
out
so his song sounds similar yeah I'm not
mad at deontay's song there yeah
um although there's there's Steven
Seagal UFC 280. hey how do we get a hold
of Steven Seagal for him to be the first
sponsored thick boy
he's like so thick now yeah oh boy he
doesn't look real anymore and he just
wears that like Sensei ghee thing with a
huge scarf he he made he was a dime in
the 80s you ever seen him in the 80s it
was all chiseled up in shape probably
not eating carbs lean big shoulders that
boys thick super speaking of thick Jake
Paul posted this video recently calling
out Tyson Fury
[Music]
oh it's all fake
[ __ ]
all right
that trouble just that dude the titties
the tattoos the stomach I mean his team
probably he had to sit there and make up
but still yeah that's what he does
remember that's you know his job's being
a boxer but then also being a content
creator that's what's going on there and
probably goes
and Jake is fighting this weekend
against Paul Anderson Silva is this
Saturday we will have a fight campaign
calabas fight campaign you have Frank
Mayer Jesse on fire Sam tripley myself
doing a fight companion for Jake Paul
Anderson Silva the fight that makes me
more excited than anything on this
entire card is the co-main event which
is Uriah Hall versus Le'Veon Bell I I'm
so
your house dream apartment for years he
is a [ __ ] Savage I just I hope
Le'Veon Bell knows what he signed up for
and I know it's just boxing there's no
kicks but
you're a holiday Savage I'm just excited
for that one for a variety of reasons
but Jake Paul are still up it's gonna be
a fun one they also have Calvin kator
and also Arnold Allen Arnold Allen I've
been on his British nuts for a hot
second he is my dark horse in the
featherweight division he beats Calvin
Kadar it's Off to the Races Calvin's our
boy he's been a food truck a million
times Calvin you know I love you I don't
like this match up for him I assume he's
a slight Underdog for a reason
and then uh you have Max Griffin Tim
Means by the Night written all over it
yeah uh Veranda Waldo on there that's a
good one and then also a great fight on
this card especially kick off the main
card is Dustin Jacoby and Cleo Roundtree
Jacoby quietly has been starching people
after coming off the Dana White
Contender series
quietly racking up the winds so he's won
one two three four five six seven eight
nine so he has one draw she's won eight
out of nine fights one was a draw but
and since he's gotten to the UFC he's uh
undefeated
he and he's flying on the radar and you
know I thought he was gonna get a top 10
Guy the game Khalil Roundtree I think
this is khalil's last fight I think I
think he retired before but it might be
his last one
Khalil was on food truck with my
favorite human beings on the planet
absolutely love Khalil and Jacoby has
some uh Denver Roots I hate that they're
fighting each other uh room for my boy
Khalil for sure though so that's why you
got performance of the night he also has
his business where he makes dope custom
sneakers he made me some red thick boy
um dunks uh I'll probably I'll wear
those on the companion for him I just
gotta remember but uh shout out to
Khalil go check him out Calvin kater
Arnold Allen Main Event so we're doing a
fight campaign for what how are we gonna
do a case we're doing just for the main
event and then
they're fun what time does it start at
though five PST
five and then when's Jake Paul start
seven it says nine on Showtime but I'm
not sure what time like is it yeah she's
so yeah but if it takes our time they
won't probably walk till around eight
maybe they come in about 7 30.
yeah
yeah we'll figure out we'll let you guys
know we're gonna figure out but bottom
line is we're definitely doing a fight
command for Jake Paul Anderson Silva and
uh Uriah Hall and Le'Veon Bell and then
hope we might added the main event for
Calvin kater Arnold Allen but either way
the fight depends going down Cal
basketball fight companion I would say 7
P.M Pacific is the safe one but we'll
announce if we do do the main event for
commentator Arnold Allen and you have
Sam tripley Jesse on fire Frank Mayer
myself come tune in come get some I'll
be fresh off the plane from Calgary
this week I'm in Calgary Thursday show
uh damn near sold out right away so we
added a show Friday that's at the
Rooftop in downtown Calgary Canada
Canada a I'm coming I haven't been in a
hot second Calgary Europe this Thursday
Friday and then Saturday we have the
fight companion on thick boy YouTube
next week one of my favorites in the
world LOL San Antonio Texas November 3rd
through the 5th I will be at the hotel
Emma my favorite Hotel on the planet but
San Antonio Texas the week after I'm in
Houston Texas at the Houston Improv
November 10th through the 12th in San
Antonio Houston we're hoping Calgary
hopefully gets up there in time
but especially San Antonio and Houston
Houston and San Antonio are two of our
biggest uh markets for Tiger thick that
thick nectar so we'll be doing meet and
greets and uh signings and tastings at
the specs out there in Santo and Houston
for both of those for the tiger thick
whiskey so come on out we'll have
bottles at each venue we'll have more
bottles we sold out in the first two
shows in Salt Lake City in the tiger
thick so we'll have more bottles in
Calgary for you hopefully it makes it
through customs and then Santo and
Houston I can guarantee we'll have all
the bottles so anybody that wants to try
that sweet nectar we will have it in
person tiger thick and Santo in Houston
and you'll be able to come meet me chill
with me Chow me arm wrestle what the
hell you guys want to do take pics taste
the tiger thick and then also buy
bottles of tiger thick at the specs in
San Antonio and Texas and Houston Texas
I'll be blasting out on social media
what specs exactly I'll be at in Texas
but I'll let you guys know and then we
end uh November in Milwaukee December
Providence Rhode Island and Washington
DC D.C DC and problem my faves tickets
at thickboy.com that's it kids if you
missed the Salt Lake City fight command
for the
Infamous UFC 280 go watch it right now
it's available on thick boy YouTube
right now we have a new Green Room diary
dropping about me being a free agent and
religion and Mormons that's dropping on
my comedy channel be all over social
media as well I love you guys let me
know what you think thanks for liking
subscribing be nice be safe to each
other go get you some tiger thick right
now go to sleepboy.com it will show up
at your house thick boy.com that's sweet
nectar tiger things available right now
all right that's it kids love you oh
these tours shirts you see me wearing we
have it in this like what do you call it
Peach we got it in this like mint green
the new torties can only get those in
person after shows along with the collab
I did with Mike Stud uh Save a Horse
Ride A thick boy the hats the t's all
that's available only in person you
gotta come to the show so Calgary if you
want it come get it this Thursday Friday
and then next week I'm in San Antonio
and Houston tiger thick new merch all
available in person love you guys
tickets for my tours thickboy.com that's
it enjoy the fight lights this weekend
and make sure you tune in to the calabas
fight campaign with Frank mayor Jesse on
fire and Sam tripley thick boy YouTube 7
PM Pacific unless I post otherwise if
we're doing the other one all right
that's it love you guys if you're into
thick boys
like subscribe comment
and God bless America well that's not my
big one just kidding